Thanks, guys, for the great introduction.
So today we're going to talk
about something that's totally practical,
and that you can use daily in your
job.
We are going to recreate the dialup modem
in JavaScript.
So maybe you
guys have a memory of this.
(Pshhhkkkkkrrrrkakingkakingkakingtshchchchchchchchchdingdingding)
Oh, we have audio?
So this...
May sound familiar.
And bring back great memories.
Connecting to
the internet.
That's enough of that.
So once we were online, our experience
was something like this.
Yes!
Wonderful progressive loading.
Slow connection.
A beautiful thing.
So who am I?
My name is Sam Saccone.
I'm a developer at a
consultancy in Rhode Island, called Mojotech.
I write software by day, and
typically make problems on Open Source projects
at night.
So let's start off
with the question: what is sound?
So sound is vibrations that travel through
the air.
And for us, we pick up those vibrations, or
pressure changes, with
our eardrum, and it's converted to an electrical
signal that our brain
interprets, and we perceive sound.
But in this case, my computer microphone is
picking up that sound, I'm plotting the raw
DCM data onto the screen, and this
is what most of us think about sound when
we see a wave form.
An audio -- a
visualization of it.
So what is data?
And these are the -- sound and data are the
two components
that are going to help us put together a modem.
So data for a computer is
zeroes and ones.
It's binary data.
It's state, encoded.
But when we use a
computer, we don't see zeroes and ones.
We see images.
Mp3s, zip files, git
repositories.
So we understand the binary data through a
program which decodes
this binary information into formats that
we're familiar with.
That we can
perceive.
So...
How do we get data into audio?
We have our wave form and we
have our binary information.
Well, obviously it's an encoding problem.
So we
need to figure out how to do that.
Humans are pretty good at encoding data.
I'm speaking to you.
You can
understand me.
You can understand language.
You can understand what I'm
saying.
I'm communicating ideas.
However, communication breaks down when you
don't speak the language.
If I was speaking a different language that
you
didn't know, you wouldn't understand what
I was saying.
You wouldn't get any
information.
So...
Language becomes the data encoding for speech.
Meaning...
This noise that I'm making would mean nothing,
unless you knew English.
It
would just be noise.
So how, then, do computers speak?
How do computers talk to each other?
Computers don't have a voice.
Computers don't know how to say things.
Computers need a way to verbalize.
They need a language and a mechanism to
transmit information.
So...
How do we do this?
I have my two computers, I have
a wire in between them.
How do they talk?
It's a good question.
So to
understand this, I want to step back in time.
The early days of
communications.
There were three primary drivers for modern
day communications.
They needed to
be fast.
They needed to be easy to use.
And they needed to be cheap to
implement.
So obviously these three have been optimized
over time, but
anything initially was great.
So in 1792, this guy, Claude, and his brother,
were hanging out in France, and they were
out in the fields, and they heard
the bell in the church ring.
They said -- wow, that's great.
That tells me
what time it is.
They said -- well, when I'm at the house and
you're at the
field and I want to tell you to come back,
we should figure out some bell, so
we can communicate.
So they went inside and got these pans.
And said -- okay.
Well, you're in the field.
I've got this pan.
I'm going to bang on it.
And
when you hear that, you know to come back.
So it was communication over remote
distances.
People didn't have to be face-to-face.
They didn't have to walk up to each other
and say something.
They could hit
this pan, and they had this code that they
agreed on.
So for a while, that's
what they did.
They hit these pans.
They said -- hey, great.
We can talk from
great distances.
They said...
Well, our neighbors are getting kind of mad.
It's kind of loud.
We need a better way.
They said...
Well, okay.
I have this
telescope.
So how about I look at you, and you can make
some symbols, and I
can understand it.
So communication over a great distance.
So this idea
evolved and evolved, and they came up with
this idea of an optical telegraph.
It sounds fancy, but it's not.
It's this tower that you can sort of see with
these needles on either end.
And there was this code.
One was pointed here.
This meant A. And then the other side -- they
would then point that there, and
so the next station would look with their
telescope and say...
Oh, A. So they
would be able to communicate a message across
vast distances.
However, it had some downsides.
If it was foggy, it didn't work.
If it was
nighttime, it didn't work.
It took three people to operate.
So it was kind of
expensive.
And it was kind of error-prone, as you can
imagine.
If you just had
the angles -- oh, that's a B?
No, that's an A. So it was very lossy.
But this
was used in France widely, up until around
1837.
So this was a revolution.
There are these lines all over the place in
France.
People were like -- this
is modern day living.
Along comes this guy.
Samuel Morse.
So France, they were
cutting edge.
They were leading the front on remote communications.
And the United States was still in the dark
ages.
There was like one optical
telegraph line, but it wasn't really used.
So Sam Morse was hanging out in a
show in New York, because he was a painter,
of course.
And he got a letter
from his father that his wife had fallen ill.
So a guy on a horse came up,
gave him a letter -- oh, your wife is ill.
Uh-oh.
I better get home.
So he
wrote a response and sent it, and before he
even left, another horse --
actually, two days later, another person came
and delivered another letter
that said his wife had died.
He said...
Wow, I never even had time to send a
response or get home, because there was such
delay in this communication.
So
he was distraught, and he went back to Europe
for his wife's funeral, and he
met someone on the boat who said...
Hey, you heard of this thing called
electricity?
And at this time, electricity was a parlor
trick.
People didn't
understand how it worked.
It was viewed as kind of magical.
Well, look.
If I
have this magnet, and I pass a current through
this wire, this magnet changes.
And it's a concept of electromagnetism.
And he had this idea that I can create
a communication system using this electromagnetism
concept, where I pass a
current through the wire, using a rhythmic
tone, so it's both on/off, Morse
code, and also temporal.
So long dash, short dash.
So he pushed forward, came
back to the United States, eventually convinced
people that this is a real
thing.
And people didn't want to believe him, because
it was still kind of
weird.
So he actually would run wires from one room
to another, and have
people in both rooms, and send a message,
and then a third party would verify
that the message was real.
Because they thought it was some magic trick.
So
Morse code kind of swept the nation.
Everywhere was connected.
In a matter of
20 years, 30 years.
There were these telegraphy lines that ran
all across the
world.
So it made it possible for people to communicate
from one side of the
world to the other immediately.
So you could know the price of alligator skin
in New York, every day, versus once every
six months.
But people loved it.
It
made communicating to relatives in California
not take ten days.
Because that
was as fast as it could happen, before this
was invented.
It also put out of
business the Pony Express, which is unfortunate.
So okay, here we are.
We have these telegraph lines running across
the
country, across the world.
These lines are kind of expensive to run.
They have
them running under the ocean.
It's crazy.
We can talk to Europe.
Everywhere.
So this guy Emil comes along.
And he says...
Hey.
These Morse code operators,
they're really expensive to hire.
Incredibly expensive.
They're like modern
day software developers.
They can go anywhere they want.
It's like -- oh, wow,
you can transmit 90 characters per second?
You're amazing!
But he said...
Well, this is...
I need to make this easier for normal people.
So he came up
with this new code.
So not Morse code.
It's this Baudeau code.
He came up with
a keyboard, a chorded keyboard.
People could be trained on it a lot faster
and
didn't have to be highly skilled to send information.
So it became cheaper.
It's like...
Sought-after Morse code operator -- not necessary
anymore.
And
what's interesting -- Baud comes from this
guy's name.
So a baud is a single
bit of information, how much we can send per
second.
So we have one operator,
one message.
An operator on the line, you would be connected
to a single
place, patchthroughs for a single wire, and
one person could be operating at a
time.
So obviously as people wanted to send more
and more messages, this
didn't scale very well.
So Baudeau came up with a way to multiplex
sending
information.
This was a temporal multiplexing.
He realized -- hey, when people
are using these lines, most of it is empty
space, because the person has to
read the message and translate it, and there's
just a lot of blank space.
So the way this works is -- there were, like,
four or five operators at a
time.
And everyone would hear this tick.
Okay.
The second tick is yours.
Third
tick is yours.
And people would send, and on the receiving
end, they would
hear the tick, so they would know how to split
the messages.
People would send
at 30, 40 words per minute.
Hear this tick.
Okay, next person, next person,
next person.
So it allowed people to send up to, like,
240 baud.
So we were
really cruising. 1855.
It was great.
In parallel, this guy, Alexander Bell, he
made the telephone, actually.
He was working on this thing called a harmonic
telegraph, or audible telegraphy.
He figured out that -- hey, if we change the
resistance in the signal that we're sending,
we can actually create tones.
And he figured out that we could use tuning
forks on both ends, and we could
use sympathetic vibration to actually send
information between two modems, and
then stack those tones on top of each other.
So this one was sending at A,
then B, C, D. And it allowed ten signals to
be on one telegram line at a time.
Which was crazy, because it means we didn't
have to run more lines, and it was
cheaper.
So obviously this was adapted pretty rapidly
by the Morse code
community, because it meant that more operators
could operate on a single
line.
So send more messages.
Higher throughput.
It was great.
And also this
eventually led to phone lines, dedicated phone
lines, being run as well.
So
audible multiplexing.
What does that mean?
Okay.
So...
If I...
Okay.
So if we
play this tone right here...
(low tone)
And just pay attention to this.
And then I come in with this...
(higher tone)
If you're listening to one tone, you as the
receiver, it doesn't matter
what else is going on.
You can hear one piece of it.
Just like the cocktail
party effect.
You can focus in on one thing and ignore all
the noise.
Audible
multiplexing meant that the receiver could
listen to an individual tone and
transcribe it.
This was automated, obviously, but this was
the basic concept
that made multiplexing possible.
People didn't really understand that they
were stacking frequencies and then could extract
it.
But it was based on very
basic concepts.
So...
Let's step back again.
How is data encoded into audio?
Well, we're using
this thing called frequency shift keying.
So we have our frequency.
Let's
imagine the carrier signal is our base signal.
And we modulate that carrier
signal and create higher frequency sections.
So your tone goes from low to
high, low to high.
And if you look at this graph on the bottom,
you can sort
of imagine that the wider frequencies, right
there, lower, are zero, and then
one.
So we can encode state into this frequency,
using this modulation scheme.
So...
We have this idea of audio frequency shift
keying.
So an FSK only means
that we're shifting a frequency, but we could
shift a frequency that we can't
hear.
So to transmit this over phone lines, for
instance, we need to make it
in the audible spectrum.
Something we can hear.
So a 10 baud modem might sound
something like this.
(piercing tones)
(crackling)
Okay.
So slow, but you can hear the individual tones.
The frequency is
modulating from low, high, low, high.
And you can manually write down
01011101, and then you can turn that back
into information, according to
whatever coding scheme you're using.
Now, as modems get more and more
powerful, we are sending at a higher baud
rate, which a human couldn't decode.
(modem shrieking)
So that sounds more familiar to you.
That sounds like a modem.
That's only
600 baud.
As it gets faster and faster, it just sounds
like static.
So...
In
1980, I think we sort of had this breakthrough.
These through points.
We had
teletype machines.
It allowed for non-skilled operators on both
end to send
and receive messages.
So I brought a version of the teletype here
today.
So
here it is.
This is actually a telephonic device for the
Deaf that's still in
use today.
It allows a Deaf person to put a phone on
top and type and send and
receive messages.
So...
You guys can hear it.
(tones beeping and crackling)
There it is.
All right.
So what you're hearing there, if you pay attention
-- you can actually hear at the beginning
-- you can hear the low and high.
So
this is transmitting at 45.45 baud, using
Baudeau encoding.
So things invented
in the 1800s are being used today without
any change, which is pretty crazy.
So...
That's a Teletype machine.
We can send information over a phone line.
It's great.
So why did we have to do audible frequency
shift keying?
And why
does any of this make sense?
Well...
Okay.
Bell had established these phones, and people
had phone lines.
Telegraph lines
were proprietary.
Companies would pay for them, and then to
send a message
would cost money.
But a lot of people had phone lines.
So someone said...
Well, I hate having to pay for these companies
to send my information when I
already have...
I can talk to someone.
So why can't I send information?
Well,
I can hack the phone system.
So an audio FSK worked on the existing
infrastructure.
And the modem was a way to connect...
Was a way to connect
teleprinters over regular phone lines.
It demodulates and modulates data to be
sent over a normal phone line.
This might not make sense, so let me explain
it.
What the phone company does is they're smart.
They say -- okay.
When a
person talks into the phone, they use this
much of the frequency spectrum.
We
can drop out individual chunks and shift that
entire voice transmission over
to here, so you can't hear it.
So we can take all the phone calls that are
happening and jam it onto a single line, or
three or four lines.
By shifting
the audio.
So...
When people are trying to send information
over phone lines,
if they're trying to send at frequencies that
the human voice doesn't send,
and the phone lines have determined that...
Well, humans don't talk in this
spectrum or these frequencies, so we're just
going to drop them -- then your
data wouldn't send.
So the modem shifts it to act like a voice.
So you can
actually hear it, and it sounds like -- if
someone was talking.
And then the
phone company shifts it.
And then on the receiving end, the phone company
unshifts it, and then the modem takes and
shift it's to where it's supposed to
be.
So the modem is a way to send information
in a way that maybe you weren't
supposed to.
All right.
So history time is over.
Let's talk about some JavaScript.
So
recreating a modem in the browser with JavaScript.
There's a few pieces that
we need to do this.
The first is...
Oscillator node.
Pretty simple.
It allows
us to...
(modem shrieking)
We can make some cool music.
But it allows us to shift the frequency over
time.
Frequency, time, and shift.
Those were the words I said before.
And now
we can just apply that.
Put some data in it, I think.
Okay.
So...
Now we can
shift this frequency, and now we need to do
some processing of this audio
data.
So the API is in flux still.
But right now it's called the script
processor node.
And what it allows us to do is process chunks
of audio just in
time, with a given bin size and sampling rate.
Those are just words.
It
doesn't mean anything.
It's fine.
But it's important.
It allows us to look at the raw PCM data and
run some math
on it.
All right.
Okay.
So we have the first two pieces.
We can shift the
frequency, and we can look at the data.
Okay.
So now we need to take a string.
And say...
Hello!
Oops.
All right.
Okay.
Cool.
So...
String to binary.
That's
not so hard.
Just a little bit of JavaScript.
Cool.
All right.
So we have our
binary.
And we know that we can make noise.
So now we have to take this binary
and put it into our wave form.
So we know that we need to do that by shifting
frequency and modulating the frequency to
high and low.
All right.
So...
Okay.
I should have played that.
Redo this one.
Okay.
(tones playing)
Okay, sweet.
So if we look at this visualization of the
data, you can see
dark patches and light patches.
Dark patches are higher frequency.
The light
patches obviously are lower frequency.
So we're at 011.
Okay.
And you heard
it.
Okay.
So we've made another step.
We can take text to binary and encode it
in a wave form by shifting the frequency using
the oscillator node over time.
Sweet!
So...
The fun part comes next.
Which is data extraction.
So I drew a
perfect wave form for you guys, so you can
get a sense of what we're working
with.
This is the hard part.
Because we have this wave form, but how does
this
relate to binary data?
I just see a wave form.
Well, remember those words that
I said before?
The bin word?
It's weird.
So we have our bits.
0, 1.
Great.
And
we know that we're sending at a certain baud
rate.
Which is bits per second.
And we know how many bins that we get per
second.
And so we can take our bins,
which come from the script processor node,
and we can combine them together,
and we say -- okay.
The sum of these bins -- or sum -- is equal
to a single
bit.
And then that bit is 01, and then we can pass
those zeroes and ones to
our decoding, and then we're good.
All right.
With me still?
Very good.
So...
How do we get from a wave to
frequency intensity?
So we have these bins.
And I don't know how to tell you
what frequency is happening inside those bins.
So I went to Wikipedia.
And I
searched.
And then I was scared.
So...
There's this cool algorithm that this
guy made.
He was on the Manhattan Project.
Hey -- this is an algorithm for
extracting a single frequency, called the
Goertzel algorithm.
And all it does is
you tell it what frequency you're looking
for, and it tells you how intense
that frequency is.
That's it.
And it was made to run on low powered system,
so
I'm like -- yes!
Perfect for JavaScript.
And so any web audio people out there
right now -- or audio people -- were like
-- you just should have used the
bass ban filter with the high Q value.
You're right.
I should have.
And I
tried it.
Except for...
It was not specific enough, basically.
So I needed
something really fine-grained.
So I had to implement my own.
So Goertzel allows
us to extract a single target frequency over
time.
So we have our bins, we
know that they relate to a bit, and we know
the bins -- if the frequency is
high, it's a 1, and if it's low, it's a 0.
So we're going to look for the
occurrence of our high frequency, and if it's
not there, we're going to assume
it's a 0.
Perfect.
So I drew another great picture for you.
Goertzel results in something like
this.
We have our wave form, run over chunks of
the wave, and get these purple
circles.
Low or high.
And from there, you can say -- this is a zero,
this is a
one, this is a zero, this is a one, then we
get this weird bleedthrough.
What
is this?
Is it a zero or a one?
I'm not sure.
So it's still not working yet.
And I was really sad.
So we want to get this analysis to as close
to binary as
possible.
So I did some more Googling.
And I came across this thing called a
Hammy window, or a windowing function.
So since the audio that we're analyzing
is non-periodic, we get spectral leakage,
and obviously...
Come on.
So...
By
applying a hamming window, we're able to remove
noise and lobe leakage.
Because we can't have any of those lobes in
our audio.
And we use a Fourier
transform, and then it works.
Okay, cool.
So it really is like a formula.
It
sort of made it all work.
I was happy about that.
Okay.
So...
Let's look at what happens when we look at
the frequency and
intensity of our audio.
(modem shrieking)
Cool!
Let me run it again.
Okay, that looks better.
So the red is our high
bits, and you heard that lead in, the high
and then the lead in at the end.
Those are the marks, and our squawk, which
is our message, is the data in
between.
So we have this nice gap in between.
Zero and one.
Perfect.
So now we
just have to make one more step.
Of course.
One more step.
So...
Let's put it
all together.
I'm going to send this at 300 baud, because
I'm crazy.
(modem shrieking)
Okay.
That one didn't work.
Let's run it one more time.
Still got some...
There we go!
Great.
Okay.
So it worked!
(applause)
Woo!
So I'm sending text, encoding it in audio,
getting that audio, decoding it
-- well, getting it out of the wave form,
and then decoding the binary and
putting it back to text on the screen, and
it works!
So...
Pretty cool.
Obviously that was too easy.
Come on!
So what if there was noise on the line?
Like a telephone -- your mom would pick up
the phone when you're connected to
Battlenet, you're doing great in Warcraft2,
and you're like -- mom, don't pick
up the phone!
And your connection drops and you've lost.
So we've got to
handle that noise on the line.
But remember that Goertzel thing?
We could
extract single frequencies and ignore everything
else in that lobe spectral
stuff.
I think we're going to be okay.
So let's see.
So I've made some noise
on the line here.
(modem shrieking with bubbling interference)
Okay.
So...
We've got a little issue here.
So web audio is a little flaky
sometimes, believe it or not.
Especially when you're doing this.
(modem shrieking with bubbling interference)
Okay.
That's better.
So if I...
What you're seeing here is some of this
random noise is interfering with our signal.
The frequencies matching up.
But
at the same time, we're still able to reconstruct
quite a bit of the
information.
So with some more advanced methods to look
at the data,
reconstructing it would become trivial.
I'll just run it one more time.
It
works sometimes.
I promise.
No?
Okay.
Who cares?
All right.
So we're at 300
baud now.
It works pretty well.
What if we wanted more speed?
300 baud is
incredibly slow.
Well, of course we can multiplex it, and so
multiplexing in our case is --
we're actually stacking the frequencies on
top.
So I have one oscillator -- or
one high tone that's at 2200 hertz and another
at 3000 hertz and another one
-- and so on and so forth.
So at 300 baud with two multiplexers, we can
get
600 baud.
That sounds like a good number.
Let's try that.
(faster modem shrieking)
Great, it worked!
Let's go up to 1200 baud, maybe?
(even faster modem shrieking)
That's better!
Still good.
That's 1200 baud.
Let's go a little bit faster.
Let's have eight multiplexers.
(very fast modem shrieking)
Cool!
(applause)
So
we are cruising. 2400 baud.
Yes!
All right.
So...
All this basically
showed you -- this is how modems work.
And I made it work in the browser.
Works all right.
But what's interesting to think is...
How our Wi-Fi works and
how Bluetooth works.
Doesn't use frequency modulation.
It uses phase
modulation, but it's the same exact concepts.
Obviously their algorithms are
way better than mine are, and things work
a lot better, but the same
principles apply.
So we take this concept that was originally
invented in the
1830s, and we can trace it all the way up
to the modern day and how this is
working right now.
Well, okay.
Obviously that was so boring.
You need to do
more.
What else can we do?
Air gap communication with this actually works.
Google actually came out with something the
other day called Google Tone.
And
I was like...
Oh, really?
But they're using this private C API that
they
didn't tell anyone about.
They're offloading it to hardware more than
I am.
But this hardware works really nice.
Imagine you had a modem running on your
browser and someone is like -- hey, I wrote
a better version of the firmware
for your modem.
They could send you a JavaScript version of
the payload and
you could dynamically reload the firmware
on your modem.
Which is kind of
weird to think about.
So things maybe I'll do someday.
So all this code is
online, if you want it.
So yeah, hopefully this shows what's possible
with
JavaScript, and how we can step back in history,
and kind of understand where
the things that we take for granted have come
from.
Which I think is cool.
So...
Thank you for listening to me.